excuse me please if you don't just turn
your attention I okay settle down there
on 18 if we could just have it quiet I
said quiet
I said will you all just please I said
shut the [ __ ] up now I'll have your
attention we might begin I'm junior
assistant researcher done I said shut
the [ __ ] up okay like I was saying I
will be leading your orientation today
now you may all be wondering where you
are
that's classified you may be wondering
who we are that's also classified
however I can tell you that we are a
form of research facility as you may
remember one of our agents approached
each and every one of you and gave you
an offer you can either way out your
term on death row or you could volunteer
to participate in our testing facilities
for the span of one month
obviously you agreed to cooperate this
into what what do you mean you didn't
agree we told you that a few participate
you're free to go at the end of the
month who wouldn't take a day like god
excuse me god please take him yeah
so one - that one - yeah third door on
the left
Cheers like I said if you can make it
through the testing procedures we know
about hear any screaming if you can make
it through the testing procedures we let
you go at the end of the month you know
provided you cooperate fully sounds like
a good deal right
was there anyone else who then they're
gray okay then
moving on like I said provided you can
survive the entire month you get to go
free
cause it's not death sentence but no see
when I said survive I meant it like
cooperate with us you know I mean yeah
it's dangerous stuff that's why we're
using death row inmates no now most of
the stuff here was pre armors I meant
dangerous like you know the way a bomb
it's dangerous if you [ __ ] around with
it I mean you will be [ __ ] them out
of it but you should be pretty
you just do what we tell you where's
finger weapon is your toes will tingle
for a few minutes afterwards last batch
of d-class not a single one died all got
to go free at end of the month I was
there to watch them scamper back to the
wilderness myself like a bunch of
adorable homicidal kittens just do what
we tell you and you'll get to go home to
see your loving wife and kids well not
you says here you kill with your wife
and kids there must have been open to
explain the name Milton I don't really
want you to tell us how you did it I can
guess right now the end of this
orientation you will be directed down
the hall where you get your numerical
designation tattooed on your wrists and
chest this will be mostly painless and
once you hmm why your chest well and the
event of an explosion it's most likely
that it'll be the largest and TAT chunk
of meat left um okay
Oh joking of course I'm joking yes I'm
sure it's very very unlikely to happen
we haven't had an explosion for the past
two months
look at me forward spirit but but though
you will actually begin your designation
tattooed on your chest I wasn't joking
about that well if you want you can get
it removed at the end of the month no no
charge at all it's a pretty painless
procedure actually okay once you get
your new tattoo you'll be escorted to
the block alpha six this will be your
new dormitory you want eight sleep and
bathe no you were spoiled in prison you
will not be getting your own cell I
don't even have my own office
you want your own cell anyways you'll
all be under strict constant video
surveillance to ensure no shenanigans we
don't want any of that funny jail time
business here you shank someone you'll
be escorted behind the carry back to
their own pretty much if you piss us off
you get sent back to death row
yes seriously a month of testing and you
get to go free don't screw it up
okay that pretty much wraps it up any
questions
you with what name did you tag around
the Buckshot to the face
yeah your question sure we have a
fantastic team of doctors here best in
the world
don't worry about your medical insurance
here it won't matter anyways next
oh you suck into the back no it's not
too late to choose death row over here I
don't know why you in want to do it out
in the first place well maybe I joined
swastika carved into your face so I
really think you're the best at making
life decisions one more yeah you
remember the missing ear that's not
really a question no phrasing it to ask
how many chicken fate doesn't count as a
question you my mother was a sight you
say that one guard place for you just
there we go
no that's fine I'll just send the gel
around there see just stay in line and
cooperate one month and you're gone you
never have to see this place again
really it's that simple
alright next bachelor days are coming in
now guards you can just court these out
please
that's right alpha 6 ok thanks very much
really
how about Kony said she was a sign yeah
let me know when this patch gets
released this month on a watch
welcome I'm junior assistant